i kept telling my my castmates like i
think people are gonna hate gabriel i
was so concerned
paris is the most exciting city in the
world and you never know what's gonna
happen next
what can you tell us about emily in
paris season two do you guys have a
filming date as darren told you any
season two secrets give us all the deets
netflix has to you know uh confirm for
season two which
will probably happen at the end of the
month
or not i don't know much and even if i
knew
i don't think i would be allowed to sing
it all depends on
how successful the show was so hopefully
it'll happen
fingers crossed so you're staying in
paris yes
that season one cliffhanger is something
that everyone is talking about
he's decided to stay and now he's got
two girls who clearly want to be with
him what was your reaction when you
first read that that was how season one
was going to end
the last episode wasn't uh written yet
all i knew is that gabrielle was
supposed to leave for normandy so
i was left in thinking that that was it
it was
was living and they wouldn't give me too
much information and
i think they knew where they were going
but they wouldn't give me as much
information
so at the end he's not supposed to know
and they didn't want me to
you know act knowing that he was going
to stay in the end so the surprise
i got the surprise when we actually um
went to the table read yeah i remember
sitting next to lily and she was like oh
you're staying
and sloppy holder and i was like oh god
yes and i think it's great
i think it's a lot of work for darren
and the writers because
that's a lot of drama uh coming up
so you're single in paris
[Music]
i didn't know that you had a girlfriend
and just based off of his interactions
with emily
and with his girlfriend who do you think
is the better fit for him
when emily arrives in gabriel's life
he's completely lost he doesn't know he
wants to you know
access something he knows his dream
and he wants to make it on his own but
he doesn't know how to do it and
the constant pressure of camille he
feels emasculated and
i think he's pretty lost when emily
arrives in his life so
with all the things that unravel thanks
to emily you know
new job opportunity that love connection
he stopped feeling for a while i guess
stepping into his shoes
i would say is really more excited
intoxicated by the promise of
emily than camille but then we planted
so many seeds about camille
and gabriel and emily so anything can
happen at this point
i feel like camille is a pretty
intuitive woman do you think she knows
that something was going on between her
boyfriend and emily
camille the actress was telling me a lot
i'm set we knew each other before this
project
and we would have our own trailers but
she would come to mine and would just
like hang out together
she's like she's like a sister to me and
she was always telling me
camille knows she knows she knows she
knows that and and so she played it
this way she played the entire season
one knowing that she knew and
so you know that text at the end i think
is uh
is meaningful french men are flirts
just act normal when you see him but i'm
not this person
i'm the girl who shows up not the girl
who makes bad decisions
you don't come to paris to be good i
just want to commend you because i think
you did such a fantastic job
of walking that fine line between making
gabriel still really likable
but also he did technically cheat
on his girlfriend with emily do you
think he considers that cheating
well first of all thank you it's it's a
great compliment because you know when
you read that part and you're like okay
is the boy next door i need to find some
nuances and i need to
also justify the fact that he's jingled
his girlfriend and that's something i
believe in so i start from the place of
love and from that i'm like
what did influence that what made him
forget his principles and values and i
think here the question is
would you give up your values and
principles over your happiness because
for the first time he's been miserable
for a while and when emily
arrives if he feels alive for the first
time in a while so
i think he's just so lost that he's just
following
his happiness and out of curiosity he
wants to see
more about emily because she's the key
to everything that unravels after that
so this is how i justified it from his
perspective i think he knows
but he's just intoxicated by this new
vibration
normally as soon as i see someone cheat
on screen
i'm like oh i'm done but i'm still like
so charmed by gabrielle
who did such a great job that i'm just
like i'm not mad at it i'm just confused
i was you know so concerned and it was
like you you know darren i think people
are gonna hate me i
it was like no no no and i was i kept
telling my my
cast mates like i think people are gonna
hate gabriel i was so concerned and
so that's why it's such a great
compliment and and uh
thank you for that this is paris
emily in paris has become the most
talked about show
and everyone is calling you the
internet's boyfriend
how are you feeling about such a broad
title i try not to think about that
obviously my gabrielle is a character
that you know is
the boy next door so of course it's
gonna be objectified
everybody means so well it's it's
benevolent and respectful and i've been
getting a lot of positive
feedback so i'm just very grateful about
that how are your dm's i can imagine
that they're pretty full these days
yes i i turned off my notifications
because my
my boundary was lasting an hour and 30
minutes every day
it's very humbling you know all this
attention i'll let you know
in a couple months once i realized if i
realized what's going on
how i feel what has it been like for you
to receive
those direct messages that are not so
much thanking you but asking you
out i didn't get that many of those it's
been
mostly very respectful messages talking
about
the nuances the gabrielle performance
the show and everything that the show
brought to
the people and i didn't get like you
know crazy
harassing anything like marry me or
anything
and i was i was pretty you know
flattered and
fearful about that because that means
that's not the energy that gabrielle is
sending
of course he's supposed to be like the
hot neighbor but
getting those respectful messages having
that image is honestly an accomplishment
for me
i love that they were all respectful
because lately i feel like actors have
just been talking about the fact that
fans are sliding into their dms with
those cheesy and
lame pickup lines which led me to think
in french do you guys have like go-to
pick-up lines oh you're asking the wrong
person i'm so bad at this
i tried you know i tried tinder i think
six years ago
i i kept it for like 24 hours
and when i matched with a couple
people i i just you know you said hey
and then
the person hates you back and then how
are you and the person
sends you how are you as well and and
then nobody says anything because you
don't know what to say
so i i have like maybe five or six
conversations with hey hey how are you
how are you and
that's it i don't answer this i'm really
bad at this
obviously you're still navigating these
these messages you're navigating all
this new attention
um has that changed the way that you're
approaching future relationships or if
you're in a relationship right now
i'm not in a relationship with right now
but you know i don't think it changes
it changes anything i'm i have my really
close friends
and we're all i think really down to
earth and
i'm doing the job that i love i'm lucky
enough to
you know being able to live from it and
to
have such amazing experiences i'm just
pretty much the same person with
a lot of messages look i want us to win
together it's a little controversial
i like it there has been a bit of a
mixture of reviews to emily and paris a
lot of the french critics are
they have a lot of thoughts what are
your thoughts as someone who
is french and is now in this show that's
kind of blending american and french
culture
i've been you know on both both sides i
lived in l.a i knew what my friends were
thinking about paris and i've
i've lived in paris and i know paris is
so huge it's such a diverse city we're
one of the
most diverse city in the world we have
so many different nationalities and way
of
ways of thinking and ideas and and
cultures and nationalities and
so you wouldn't have enough of one life
time to
explore every aspect of paris and so at
some point you have to if you want to
tell a story about paris you have to
choose an angle she was a vision
and i think darren just chose an angle
that he knew
the one he experienced when he was a
teenager and and he added his little
signature of
fashion and colors and love and romance
we have to keep that in mind
it's supposed to be a feel-good show
it's supposed to be you know
you take your mind off from all the from
this year we all had and uh
so when people in dm send me you know
thank you i was able to escape from a
really bad year from a really bad day
and i want to go to paris and
this is the best compliment because this
is exactly why we did that show but
you know french people we like to
complain and uh
it's part of our charm but i understand
that some people need truth and reality
but
it would be a documentary otherwise some
things get lost in translation but just
know that i'm finding my way